I hope I am audible clearly so ladies and gentlemen so this today's session will be
basically related to the hands-on applications in NLP so already you have seen the theoretical
part executed by Dr. Plavon Bhoomi beautifully and where you have learned about the theoretical
aspects of NLP. Now in this particular session we are going to have some hands-on demonstrations
on NLP so those who have attended my sessions earlier they know me quite well and in a few
email communication you might have seen me actually I am Shobosachi Mukhopadhyay who
is a research scholar from Center for Computational Data Sciences at IIT Kharagpur and also I
am taking care of this particular high cohort 3. So let us start today's session so already
all of you are quite aware as per our standard practice that we implement this type of the
hands-on sessions in Google Colab. So I request all of you to open a Google Colab so as you
can see on screen all of you are quite aware with these practices as you have gone through
a multiple hands-on sessions including my two earlier sessions on supervised machine learning.
So you know how to open Google Colab go to click on the welcome to Colab and then open
a new notebook make sure that you are logged in from your Gmail account. So click on plus
notebook and it will open up and you like as per the standard practice which I have
mentioned that you can give some name like demo or something like this. So it will help
you to execute this particular portion. So you may give some name like demo here and
then you can click on keep on executing one by one part. So there are code section where
you can write some code you can click on this run cell button it will execute properly and
then you can see plus code plus text these two options are available in plus text you
can add up some text. So all of you quite aware of this but I am just telling you as a part
of the revision you can consider. Now this particular notebook link I will request moderator
to share with all of you. Remember that apart from the GitHub link notebook link will be
shared to all of you. So you can also have the access on the notebook part as well.
So this particular GitHub section if you go to my Google apart from the link those who
want to directly access my GitHub they can search in Google. So it will appear you can
directly go to my GitHub account apart from the link I am just showing how to access it.
So here you can go there and you can click on the second top repository one is in leadership
second one is the natural language processing as you can see in the screen you can click
on it and then you open the second one NLP hands on a beginner's guide you just open
it up and you can use it. So this is another option you can directly open it up from the
link given in comment box section or you can use the Google search. So this is another
option. So let us start the session. So as a just as a beginner's approach. So what
I have done I have given a few basic overview during our discussions for the sake of our
discussions. So now the natural language processing what does it imply. So from first up you have
learned that NLP is an interdisciplinary field which is merging with the machine learning
concepts computer science as well as the linguistic. So it will give you the idea to how to comprehend
and handle the human languages quite effectively. So in basically here you can see two types
of the categories key categories if I mentioned. So one is for the natural language understanding
in short we call them as the NLU and which basically focus on the interpreting and understanding
of the human languages including for example there are stocks like sentiment analysis extracting
information from the text or speech recognition text classification etc. And the other part
that is called the natural language generation energy. So what does it imply. It actually
focuses on producing human readable text from the structure data and it involves stocks
like language translation or the summarization or dialogue generation etc. So these are the
tasks we basically implement and it is being applied in many more fields. For example we
can talk about the customer support through virtual assistants or the chatbots content
analysis topic modeling which we will see in today's session also topic modeling or
the sentiment analysis or for example in the information retrieval through question and
answer system systems or the search engines etc. Now first of all we will see some of
the important NLP libraries in Python. So there are four libraries which we will discuss
and each of those libraries we will hit upon with the examples so that the concepts remain
clear to all of you. So natural language toolkits first of all we shall talk about. So it is
a very high versatile and widely used Python library for NLP task and it offers a comprehensive
set of tools and resources for text processing which includes the functionalities like stemming,
tokenization, lemmatization or for example part of speech tagging in short we call them
as the POS tagging. So these are the possible implementation which we can do in terms of
the natural language toolkit or NLTK. And besides we can talk about the spatial library.
Now there is one interesting thing that spatial library here you see C is capital can you
observe it. So Python is a case sensitive language right from my first session I am
mentioning and also Mr. Baira during his Python session also highlighted that there should
not be any kind of the error related to the upper case and lower case implementation.
It will land up with error and you will not be able to execute the course section properly.
So because of that upper case and lower case combination you have to be very careful enough.
So this in spassie the C will be capital. So it is a high performance library for the
advanced NLP task which is being used for the task like POS tagging, name, entity recognition
or in short we call them as the NIR or for example tokenization etc. And another one
will be the text block. So you all have the hands on demonstration all those tools. So
nothing to worry about it. So another interesting library that is the text block. So text block
is nothing but a user friendly library which is built on the top of the NLTK and pattern.
So it basically implement the task like noun phrase extraction or the sentiment analysis
even for the POS tagging we also use it. So it basically helps to implement a much more
sophisticated way in terms of the NLP project implementation.
And then definitely we can also spoke about the Jensen library. So it is the powerful library
for the topic modeling. It offers optimized algorithms like latent Dirichlet allocation
LDA or the doc2vec, what2vec. So it helps to implement like the generating word embedding
for beta text representation, text similarity analysis and topic discovery. Now I believe
all of you have got the idea that right from the beginning which you have discussed that
NLP is two parts of the implementation angle natural language understanding and natural
language generation.
We have spoken about the examples, few of the few important examples which we have seen
in our daily life and then four important libraries which we are going to implement
through the hands-on part. So I repeat NLTK, SPACI, text block and Jensen. Now first part
that is the data preprocessing as well as text cleaning.
So during machine learning session you may remember I mentioned that data preprocessing
is very very important. Whatever the optimized algorithm you may use if your preprocessing
steps are not correct you are not going to land up with the proper result. So because
of that reason in NLP also your data preprocessing is very much important.
So here we are going to use the two important things that will be the natural language toolkit
NLTK and another one will be the regular expression RE. So steps in the code so what
are the steps we are going to implement these are the very basic beginning remember the
steps what we are going to follow. So first step will be lower casing, converts the text
to lower case. First step second one will be removing the punctuation not only punctuation
including the special character as well. So punctuation and special character you have
to remove it and third one will be the tokenization. So in tokenization what you will do you will
split the text into individual words. For instance the sentence I love programming
you can tokenize it like I love programming you are splitting the sentence into three
individual words. So this is called tokenization then the removal of the stop words.
So it filter out the very common words like for example the is which are present in the
sentence which are not the essential part of the NLP. So that you can do and the lemmatization.
In the lemmatization what we are doing reducing the word to its base from running to run.
So I repeat the steps which we are going to follow first of all we will do the lower casing.
This is the lower casing part converting the text to lower case first of all. Second one
is the removing the punctuation it will strip out all the punctuation or the special character
which are present here. Third one is the tokenization splitting the sentence into individual words
and then removing stop words is and we are going to remove it removing stop words because
these are not the essential part of the NLP task. So we are removing it and then finally
the lemmatization. The lemmatization what we are doing we are reducing the words to
their base from running to run keeping to keep in this way.
Now let us start our hands on part. So I request all of you to open your Python I mean open
the Google Colab already you have opened it up and you have given some name like demo
if you have followed my earlier instruction and those who have not directed please do this
part. So I am going back to my original demo window. So here what we will do? So first
of all it will be import RE. It will import the regular expression which is very much
important for the text pre-processing purpose. Then from NLTK import NLTK we will import
the NLTK part. It is very much important for the tokenization and other NLP related task
implementation NLTK stands for the natural language toolkit and then from NLTK dot corpus
import stop words. So we will import all the stop word corpus from NLTK. So you will see
lot of common stop words which are present which will load and then from NLTK dot tokenize
we shall import the word underscore tokenize. So it will make the word tokenization implementation
from NLTK. So it will all the necessary tasks related to the NLP you can do it easily like
for example here I have mentioned like it can help to split a text into individual words.
So it will basically implement a tokenization operation which I mentioned earlier. So just
a second you can remember that which I have mentioned earlier that each of the cases with
the codes I have also added some explanation for you with the has sign. So you can easily
follow and you can easily implement it for your execution purpose. Then from NLTK dot
stem we shall import the ordinate lemmatizer operation. So it will do the all the lemmatization
operation. So you already have seen that we will go back to our source word the base form
of the word keeping to keep or for example running to run in this way. So I am just clicking
on the run cell button and meanwhile it is executing. So I shall go back and I am just
showing you another interesting code sharing tool that is snippet.io. So just for your knowledge
purpose I am sharing it. This particular link will not be required for all of you as I have
already shared my Github link as well as the notebook link. This is just for your knowledge
purpose I am just mentioning that snippet.io is a very good code sharing platform. Like
for example as you can see I have written all those codes but I can give this particular
link to all of you. But the problem is that if you make any changes in the code during
copy pasting or during reproducing the result, I do not have the control on this. So that
is the reason I am not sharing here because there are 1190 amount of the participants.
So it will be very difficult to control through a snippet.io. So that is why I have not shared
this particular link. It is good for the small crowd for example in classroom based small
crowd. It is very much easy for controlling purpose but here it will not be easier to
control that is why I have not shared it rather I have given my notebook link and Github link.
So that all of you can easily implement. But for your knowledge purpose I have just mentioned
that snippet.io is also a very good platform where you can also execute, you can share
the codes mutually and it is a very good effective code sharing platform during the hands-on
practices. Anyway so let me go back to my original notebook. So as you can see it has
implemented the green tick has appeared and the running execution time is 7 seconds.
So it is now 11.28. So I think 11.30 would be good enough to implement this particular
portion. All of you please implement it. Then we shall go ahead for downloading the NLTK
resources. So remember we first imported RE that is for the importing of the regular expression
module. Second one we have imported the NLTK or the natural language toolkit. Third one
we have imported the stop words from NLTK.corpus. Then in the next step what we have done we
have word_tokenize which we have imported for implementing the tokenize operation and
then we also have imported the wordnet lemmatizer to implement the lemmatization operation.
So these are the basic parts which we have implemented. Then once you complete the step
by 11.30 we shall move to the next step of downloading the NLTK resources. So what we
will do here? So we will basically download punk. So it is one of the tokenizer model
which are necessary for the tokenization all type of the supports you will get from here.
Then the next part will be for the stop words. So you will get and download all the necessary
stop words from the which are required for the English languages. So you can do it from
here. Then NLTK.download wordnet. So it will download the wordnet lexicon for a large lexicon
database of English. So then we can also give the additional support of the NLTK.download
with the help of the punk tab. So these are the resources which we will download. So already
I have explained to all of you. So once you finish it then you implement this next portion
in your Google collapse cell. So it is now 11.30 so I believe all of you have been able
to finish it up. So just do it. Also I am doing it for you. So done. As we can say the
green tick has appeared with the execution time 0 seconds. So please complete this step.
So it is 11.30 please complete this step by 11.31. So once you finish it up we will go
to a example text and step by step we shall implement all those necessary operations.
Because we can see similar type of the implementation everything I have given in my snippet.io.
So those who are attending the session just make a note of it snippet.io is a good platform
for code sharing purpose. You yourself can explore it out. But remember that once you
share with the participants for example if you can use it for your own teaching purpose
learning purpose but you will not have the control. If he or she makes any changes then
it will be difficult for time bounded sessions. So that is why the safer side is to share
the course with the help of the GitHub links or even Collab links. These are much safer
for core sharing purpose.
So let us start discussing the next part. It is already 11.32 so I believe that all of
you have completed the earlier step that is downloading the NLTK resources. And the next
step what we are going to do here we shall basically discuss about the let me just tell
it from here also here every portion is written. So basically this is the example text. So
as you can see this is an example sentence to the state text preprocessing we shall clean
it and tokenize. So as you can see under double code we have written a sentence and we have
assigned it as text.
And now as you can see deliberately whatever the to implement all the basic operations
related to NLP what we have added that in the text which is containing capital letters
top words which we want to remove actually or for example in case of capital letter we
will convert into the lower case. So all those operations we shall perform. So to execute
those things first of all those attributes should be in the original sentence otherwise
you will not be able to do that operation and then also it can contain the punctuation.
If the punctuation will be there then only you can remove it. So keeping those factor
in the mind we have given a one sentence. So if you are for example if you are reproducing
these results and then you want to find out one particular similar type of the sessions
for yourself or to you want to teach somebody else. So make sure the reference sentence
you want to gives everybody is different from this particular sentence that should contribute
this type of the attributes then only we shall be able to implement all those things because
at the first step you have to convert it into the lower case letter.
So first of all what we are doing we are defining a function that is preprocessed text. So
def preprocess underscore text the first the argument which will pass that is the text
which we have stored a given sentence and then what we are doing we are lower casing
the text. So text equals to text dot lower. So it will convert all the upper case material
to lower case and then what we will do in the next step as per our standard practice
which we have learned from this notebook section you can go to the original notebook
and you can cross check remove the removal of the punctuation and special characters.
So in this way we have step by step we have implemented here. So here also in the next
part what we shall do we shall remove the punctuation and the special character.
So text equals to dot read or sub. So what we will do we will remove all the punctuation
and the special characters and that is why the text which function we are taking that
should be given there under the read or sub function. And then what we will do we will
tokenize the text. So this particular case what will happen it will split the text into
the individual words. So basically like for example I am running I am running. So three
parts it will split and then remove stop words. So here set stop words dot English. So it
will load a set of the stop words from the NLTK library and it will store it under the
stop words. And then tokens word for word in tokens if word are not in stop words.
So under tokens it will only preserve those materials which are not the stop words. The
part of the sentence which will be preserved there those are not the stop words. Stop words
will be chopped out. And then the lemmatizer, lemmatizer word, word net lemmatizer operation
we shall implement under the lemmatization. So word not word net in lemmatizer we will
create an instance. Name to word net lemmatizer we will store it under lemmatizer and lemmatizer
dot lemmatize word for word in tokens. So lemmatization part operation will be applied
over all the tokens which we have extracted out from a sentence. Like for example running
to run, keeping to keep in this way the lemmatization operation will happen. And then finally we
shall return the tokens which are cleaned basically which will be cleaned from all those
the stop words part and entire part will be tokenized and the lemmatized.
So let us execute this particular portion. So you can see it has run the cell successfully.
So implement this particular segment of the cell. Start from the example text and then
complete up to this return tokens. So it is now 1037. So this is little bit of larger chunk
of the code. So what you do you implement it by 1141 and while implementation go through
the instructions carefully each line although I have explained but it will be better for
you that if you yourself can read it. So you can you can scroll it a bit. If you want to
read the comments present in the code you can you can move it like this. So the left
hand side will go you can see the code the right hand side you will move you can see
all those important implementation steps are highlighted which I have mentioned during
the execution part.
So make sure that you are doing it properly. So I repeat the steps we have taken my meanwhile
you are implementing I am just repeating the steps just for your so that all of you can
follow it and for your assistant purpose all the instructions are written with the hash
sign. All of you know that right from the beginning I am mentioning during the supervised
learning sessions I also highlighted that I have added some some comments so that all
of you can easily understand. So example text we have considered one text which comprises
of the capital letter stop words punctuation etc. Then we have from the pre process text
function under that we first have implemented the lower casing operation. Then with the
reserve function where we have taken the text as an input and we have removed all the punctuation
of the special characters. So here w stands for the word characters and s for the space
characters.
So now we have tokenized the text so we have implemented the tokenized operation then we
have removed the stop words and finally the lemmatization operation and then we have returned
the tokens which are basically cleaned tokenized stop word free and lemmatized. So this is
what we have implemented as per our standard discussion which we have made during the original
load book.
I repeat I am repeating it again because there are lot of people who are new to NLP and as
well as the new to Python programming. So if I re-explain twice or thrice it will be
easier for them to follow it up a bit. So that is why I am re-explaining it and those
who are already expert kindly cooperate because or you can also consider it as a good revision.
So anyway so let us implement this portion and then we shall move by it. So complete
up to return tokens complete up to this. This is the last line of this will be the last
line of execution. So I shall wait for another more minute and then we shall process the
example text as a part of the next implementation and we will be able to see the clean tokens
as an output. So this part we will implement very soon. So complete up to return tokens
and then we shall move on to the next part. So complete up to return tokens. So complete.
I shall wait for few more seconds. So I believe all of you are doing it and while implementing
it is not only running the course understanding the each line of the code and when you are
getting output interpretation of the output are also very important. So that is why I
am telling just call a bit and read the comments given there. Although I have basically explained
what are happening in each case but it is always better that if you go to the right side and
also you are reading them. Now in the next part it is already 1141. So I believe that
all of you are quite okay if I move to the next part.
So process the example text. So pre process under course text you are applying this function
over text and you are storing it under the clean text and then we are printing the clean
token. So in the clean tokens you can see the output after once we implement this particular
portion we will be able to see all those clean tokens. So in the clean tokens you can see
example sentence demonstrate text pre processing well clean tokenize. So these are the clean
tokens as simple as that because this was the original sentence and after the pre processing
steps implementing pre processing step successfully we are getting this particular segment as
an output. So I believe now it is quite clear to all of you.
So please implement this step. So it is now 1142 please implement this one within a minute
by 1143 please complete this particular step. Then we shall go ahead for implementing the
specific from the original notebook this is the part.
So I hope all of you are finishing this I shall wait for 20 minutes.
And then move to the next portion of discussion. So in those who are following my Github you
will get this output and those who are following it from directly from the notebook they will
get this output. I mean same output but I am just showing so that all of you can remain
in the same page. So from Github this is the output which are highlighted in the screen
and same output you will get those who are directly implementing from the notebook.
Anyway so let us move to the next part. Now before going to the next part as a summary
which we can say that this particular chunk of code which we have implemented. So here
we have demonstrated the cleaning and pre processing text using the NLTK where we have
covered different steps. At the beginning we have done the lower casing then we have
removed the punctuations as the vessel character and then followed by the tokenization removal
of the stop wars and lemmatization. So these were the steps which we have implemented.
And this pre processing pipeline is very much important for preparing the raw text data
which you can implement for several tasks led to the sentiment analysis or for the text
classification and other relevant natural language processing or the NLP task.
So like we have discussed in the notebook first portion is done. Implementation of the
NLTK toolkits we have done. Now as I have mentioned that in each case each necessary
or important NLP libraries in Python we shall discuss one by one. So first portion is done
now we shall move to the SPACI. Now it is done for SPACI. So before implementing SPACI
let us discuss a few important part. Part of speech tagging and named entity recognition.
So in part of speech tagging we call them in short as POS and named entity recognition
we call them in short as NER. So background concept and the steps in the code which we
will implement we shall load this SPACI model. So here we will be able to see an encode which
is a lightweight model that includes the NER stands for the named entity recognition or
POS which is the abbreviated format of the part of speech tagging as well as tokenization.
So in the part of speech tagging each word in the text is stuck to the grammatical role
it can be pronoun, verb, adjective or adverb. So let us one of the simple example which
you can consider a particular sentence that is that the quick brown fox jumps over the
lazy dog. This is the sentence for example if you are considering. The quick brown fox
jumps over the lazy dog if this is the sentence. So here how we are going to discuss about
the POS tags. So from your basic knowledge of the school level English whatever the whether
you have English as a first language or second language does not matter. These are the very
basic steps you all have learned during our school level. So in POS tags like for example
the, there is a determiner in NLP we deal with the abbreviated form as DT. Just you just
made learning thing will be the abbreviated form otherwise you will not be able to understand
what is the POS tagging coming up. So that is why this we are discussing this particular
part. Then for example the quick, quick is adjective in abbreviated form in NLP which
we follow it is JJ. Then brown is also adjective definitely it will be JJ as an abbreviated
annotation. Fox now so we shall follow it as NN. Then jumps VBZ in is the abbreviated
form over preposition. So here we follow it as IN then the determiner as DT then lazy
adjective as JJ dog as NN. Now so there we can talk about a few more examples. This has
been extracted from this given sentence. You can cross check the given sentence and you
can check their corresponding POS tags. We will be able to understand it. Now we shall
still have a look on the few of the overviews of the other POS tags and their categories.
So here you can see personal pronouns which we call it as PRP like I, you, he, she, it,
we, they, these are the personal pronouns or for example positive pronouns. In the next
part which we can say positive pronouns. So how it is being differentiated with the personal
pronoun we add up a dollar sign with it. So like my, your, his, her or we can talk about
it is our their number. So these are the basically the positive pronouns which you can execute.
So also remember that there will be common question which often comes in our mind. Then
what will be in case of the number? So in number we do not have any specific tag but
in general we call it as the cardinal number. So the abbreviated form is CD. So it can be
1, 2, 3, some other numbers 100, 142, 42. So we tag it as CD. So we have spoken about
the pronoun, we have spoken about the cardinal numbers. Now we will see some of the interesting
tags that are the adverbs. So the more you will practice it you can remember nothing
to worry about it, nothing to worry about it. But I am just discussing because it will
help you to see that how NLP deals with it that is it.
So like for example adverb. So in adverb like for example quickly very well we call them
we basically annotate them as the RB. Or for example if you are comparing adverbs there
are also the adverbs which we compare like faster, better, smarter in this way. So there
are comparative angles. So in the abbreviated form we write them as the RBR. Then another
one is the superlative. Now superlative all of you know fastest, best, smartest, tallest,
shortest. So these are the superlative game. So here you can see we can abbreviate it from
we can keep it as the RPS. And then some of the angles that are the punctuation which comes
up. So like for example full stop. So you can keep them as a period or for example punk
these are the general punctuation.
So basically full stop we write it as the annotation for this dot this is basically stands for
the period. Then for example comma question mark exclamation mark in this way you can
see there are other punctuation part. And also there are symbols which comes under the
sign categories like exclamatory or the percentage or the or the ampersand at the rate or this
dollar sign. In this way these are the few of the symbols which you can consider which
comes under this. So these all are the part of the POS tag which we have discussed here.
Now here we shall move for the name entity recognition. The name entity recognition some
of the very interesting case. Like for example the sentence which is given the Barakovama
visited the Eiffel Tower. Here we are also taking one particular sentence. Barakovama
visited the Eiffel Tower in Paris last summer. For example this is the sentence. Now what
are the NER tags or the name entity recognition? Barakovama person name here or the Eiffel
Tower location in short we are giving them as the lock or for example Paris it is also
a location in short we are writing as the lock.
So in this example as you can see NER or the name entity recognition helps to identify
and categorize the specific names and location in the text. So this is how the interpretation
is done. Now let us start the implementation in our original Python notebook section.
Now let us start with the importing SPACI. So in what we will do? It is a very much advanced
NLP library SPACI. So we are loading it up. Then what we will see? We shall load the SPACI's
English model. So as we have seen we have we are loading the this small or lightweight
English language model NSM score offset with the help of this SPACI load and we are storing
it under the NLP. And then what we are doing? We are putting a sample text there. So like
here the sample text is Apple is looking at buying UK startup for 1 billion USD. Steve
Jobs founded Apple in 1976 and we are storing it under text. So here we have seen the basically
presence of the named entities and some of the financial information etc. Now we can
process the text using SPACI. So we are applying the NLP function over text and we are storing
it under doc. Now our target will be to extract two part. One is the POS tagging and then
will be the named entity recognition. So POS tagging what we will do? We will print POS
tagging. So part of speech tagging will be implemented one by one. POS tag will be printed
one by one. So for token that is why this particular for loop is implemented for token
in doc. Print token dot text, token dot position and token dot tag. So token present in the
text they are part of speech tagging token dot POS that means that part of speech tagging
and their original tag token dot tag which is present in the NLP that would be printed
one by one. So like for example just one example case I am mentioning like is auxiliary verb
then VBG is the corresponding tag. Looking again verb their corresponding tag is VBG.
So in this way you can see noun verb different symbols numbers which are present in the text
you can cross check by yourself or punctuation marks or some cardinal number like 1976 is
the cardinal number. So their corresponding tag is CD. So in this way so the tokens they
are their corresponding POS and the tag. These three things are being printed like the way
it has been printed here. So you can yourself just check the output and try to understand
it with the concept which is been shared in the notebook and as well as in the GitHub
link.
Same thing is will be printed for the named entity recognition. So print named entities
so for ENT in doc ENT print ENT dot text their ENT dot level add spastic explanation. So
as you see in the output named entity the way we are printing it. So first portion if we
see in the code that is ENT dot text. So here what is this first portion is the apple then
what we are printing ENT dot level. So what is the level here if this is the apple that
means it is an organization and then what we are printing the spastic explanation of
that ENT level.
So this organization can be what are those organizations it can be companies it can be
agencies it can be institution etc. Similar way or for example 1 billion USD. That is what
type of that that is money. Now this money can be a monetary values or it can be a including
it a possible unit may be there. So in this way you can check out Steve Jobs, Apple or
their dates like for a Steve Jobs is a person. This person can be a pupil including fictional
characters may be or for example Apple which is an organization. This organization can
be like which we have discussed here companies or agencies institution because here Apple
has appeared twice. That is why it is appearing twice. At the beginning Apple is looking at
buying UK startup for 1 billion USD Steve Jobs founded Apple in 1976. So that is why it has
appeared twice in named entity recognition part.
In 1976 it is a date. Now it can be absolute or relative dates or certain periods. So explanation
possible what is that thing that explanation is coming under this parenthesis. So just
implement this chunk of the code and just see the interpretation like I told you that
running code successfully is one thing and understanding each steps and their output
is also very important. So I have just two or three out of these output I have mentioned
two or three examples what they are actually implying yourself try to understand it. Just
cross check with the output. So it is now 1157 and by 12 you just finish this part. So
I think 3 minutes will be good enough to finish this part. Then we shall summarize it and
move to the sentiment analysis part.
Thank you.
. So those who are getting the output just have a look at the output.
Name the entities and POS tagging so you yourself will be able to understand it. The English
angle it is a very basic level of English which you have learned in our school days.
Nothing to worry about. Just corresponding their tags how they are being interpreted
in NLP that is very much important just to know. The concepts are very simple. So I shall
wait for another more minute and then move to the next part.
So those who are now new to the coding but gradually getting familiar with the coding
for them I am just saying like I mentioned in each session that the way you will print
in this order you will see the output. Like in the first case of the POS tagging token
text token POS or part of switch tagging and then their corresponding tag. Token dot part
of switch and their corresponding tag will be printed in this order. So like for example
buying it is the token present in the text. I am repeating it again. I already have explained
I am just repeating for example those who are new they can easily see it. Then bar this is
for the token part of switch. Then their corresponding tag POS tag in NLP we use it as VBG as simple
as that. Similarly ENT dot text ENT dot label and SPACI dot explain for the ENT that can
be also doable in any year or the entity recognition.
So like the example which I have taken for example this particular case 1976 which is
a date and explanation as a part of that it can be absolute or relative date or certain
period can be considered which is the explanation. So I believe all of you are now able to understand
it please finish it up. I shall wait for few more seconds and then we shall move towards
the next part that would be the sentiment analysis part.
So as a summary we can mention that this particular examples in this particular examples which
we have seen that how to use SPACI for this two key NLP task one is the any a name entity
recognition the other one is the previous tag or the part of switch tag. These are very
much essential for understanding and the meaning of the text and their structure.
So I believe that all of you are now getting some confidence especially those who are new
in NLP those who know I already mentioned finally considered as a good revision but at
least those who are new I hope that all of you are getting some confidence. So that after
reproducing this result you yourself can play around with your own examples and understand
that how it is happening. So it will give you a lot of confidence regarding the text
processing and the text analysis part under NLP as well as machine learning.
Now the sentiment analysis portion so here we will see sentiment analysis in Python using
the text block library. So as you can see in the original discussion this is the third
important NLP library which I mentioned at the beginning. You see when we discussed about
the important NLP libraries in Python first part we have spoken about the NLTK natural
language toolkit then we have spoken about the SPACI and the third one is the text block.
Now let us discuss this part. Now from text block import text block then the next sample
text will come up. So under the text we are writing I absolute love this product it is
fantastic and works like a charm and then we shall create a text block object.
So here what we will do we will apply text block function over text and we shall store
it under block like what we have done here and then block dot sentiment we will store
it under sentiment that is performing of the sentiment analysis and then output sentiment
polarity and the subjectivity. So from print polarity sentiment polarity you will see the
polarity so minus 1 is the negative to plus 1 positive and then we will also see the subjectivity
by printing subjectivity sentiment or subjectivity 0 is the objective 1 is the subject. Now before
implementing coding part I am explaining the concept related to the polarity and subjectivity
then we will implement it we will get the score we will try to understand the interpretation
that is a separate thing we will go that but before going printing this portion I am just
explaining this part what is polarity as you can see in the screen it measures the sentiments
positivity or negativity. So if it is minus 1 then it is negative if it is 0 then it will
be neutral if it is 1 then it will be positive as simple as that.
Similarly for the subjectivity subjectivity it will range from 0 to 1 as we can see highlighted
portion in the screen it will range from 0 to 1. So 0 means objective and 1 means subject.
It will indicate whether the text is based on the fact or personal opinion that means
if you are quoting getting score 0 that is fact sun rises in the east it is a fact. So
it is objective but subjective means personal opinion personal bias will be there. So that
means if you are going getting score 0 or near by 0 it is more objective cases if you
are getting score 1 or near by 1 it will be subjective case personal bias personal opinion
like if I say for example that Sachin Tendulkar is my favorite cricketer if I say just for
an example. So it is sharing my personal opinion it is a subjective case you may have some
different opinion right. So it is a subjective case.
So in this way we define the polarity and subjectivity. So let us implement this particular
portion now 1 by 1 and let us calculate the polarity and the subjectivity case. As you
can see polarity here you have got the value 0.5125 and the subjectivity 0.75. We shall
go for this interpretation of the output first you implement this chunk of the code and then
we shall go for the interpretation purpose see the output. So as you can see the grinting
has appeared with the 0 second and we got the polarity and the subjectivity score.
So before going to the for the interpretation you just implement this is 12.6 please finish
this step by 12.8 and then we shall move towards the interpretation purpose.
So let us go for the interpretation purpose. So first we shall go for the interpretation.
So first I shall go for the interpretation purpose. So first I shall go for the interpretation
purpose. So first I shall go for the interpretation purpose.
So those who have implemented fine those who are still doing it please complete it make
sure that you are not making any mistake if you are typing make sure that you are typing
correctly those who are copying the cells make sure that you are copying properly and
understanding these steps because each explanation is given with the hash sign and also check
the outputs which you are getting I shall explain them very soon.
So I shall wait for another more minute and then move to the next step. So please make
sure that all of you are implementing it smoothly. Understanding is very much important for each
of the operations. So remember that we are implementing the sentiment analysis part.
So I hope now it is quite clear to all of you that how the text block performs like we have
planned for the NLTK library of this passive. Now you are quite aware of the text block
. Now you see that we have got the polarity value 0.5125 and the subjectivity value
is 0.75. Now what does the imply? So as you can see polarity value we have learned that
if it is minus 1 it will be negative it is 0 it is neutral and if it is 1 then it is positive.
Now 5125 is at some type of the moderately positive but not so overwhelming. So this
particular language conveys that it has a general favorable tone but not very much optimistic
or enthusiastic. So it is moderately positive around 0.5125 it is moderately positive. Similarly
for the subjectivity score it is 0.75. Now as we have learned that it is 0 then it is
a fact or nearby 0 it is nearby facts. So around objectivity will be there something
related to the objectivity will be there but the more it will go towards 1 especially over
0.5 that has a stronger subjectivity. That means the personal opinion or the personal
bias will be strong there. So if I say with a subjectivity score of 0.75 the text contains
a strong personal bias subjective expression or opinion rather than it is a purely based
on facts or the objective analysis. Hope now it is quite clear to all of you.
So this portion of the code what we have learned it has shown us sample text which is moderately
positive with a significant degree of subjectivity and text blob is simply effective for the
sentiment analysis task. So in this segment we have learnt about text blob their functionalities,
polarity and subjectivity and how to implement text blob for sentiment analysis. In the next
part we shall go and implement for the topic modeling and document clustering. So there
will be a break of 5 minutes and then we shall start our discussions on the topic modeling
and document clustering. Stay tuned.
[BLANK_AUDIO]